[Music]
all right so everything that we spent
the first 30 some-odd minutes talking
about it sort of leads to academic
integrity yes it sounds like to me that
these that we need not only the the
students to have some integrity but the
administrators the professor's
everything else everyone at the
University all together do you think
that's a fair assessment
absolutely in fact I think that we often
confuse the terms academic freedom and
academic integrity would we really care
about his academic integrity first and
foremost an academic integrity really
means that I'm not gonna sell my soul or
my ideas based on the highest bidder I
believe that you know and this is again
the search for truth that requires
integrity and then of course I have the
freedom to collaborate with people
including donors on areas where we find
mutually beneficial relationships and
win-win trade yeah so one of the things
that you talked about I referenced it
earlier in one of these quotes that you
really focus on is upward mobility yes
and it I think it's particularly
interesting right now because if you
listen to some of our political leaders
it seems like we've sort of completely
lost the ability that we you know we're
separated by class and all that you come
from a place where upward mobility was
very hard it's gotten less hard as
they've embraced as India has embraced
capitalism first I guess in the most
broad sense tell me why you think upward
mobility is so important but more
importantly what's the state of it in
America right now so I actually think
that we in the United States focus on
upward mobility as if this was a major
problem in the u.s. other countries are
becoming more market oriented than the
United States the United States still
stands as the one place where you really
really have the ability to be upwardly
mobile and I think that is the greatest
asset that the United States still have
and I'm very proud to
all this country my country of choice so
let's sit in that idea for a second
because I totally agree with it and it
seems to me that all of the people who
say that's not true are missing that our
laws here allow you to do whatever you
want with your life it doesn't mean that
you are gonna do it it doesn't mean that
it's gonna be handed to you yes but as
you just said as an immigrant that came
here that has become tremendously
successful you're living proof that you
can do it
absolutely and that still holds in fact
in some ways I think we so take these
laws for granted that we don't know what
the rest of the world is out there so my
daughters have grown up and been born in
the United States but I think that their
biggest learning moments come when they
leave the country and see things even in
India today as they as it exists they
see the disparities of the things that
they can take for granted versus in
India but you still have to fight with
the corruption you still have to fight
with the status aspects the United
States is very status free relative to
most other countries including India and
there's a dignity to human labor here
that is often missing in many other
cultures that is the aspect that I care
about when I care about upward mobility
and you know what let's be honest out
here I did not have the kind of
privileges that my daughters do I could
be mourn the fact that you know I came
from a country or from a traditional
family values that I had to the family
tradition there was such that I had to
have this fight that for sure defined me
positively but also caused some
psychological scars and of course my
hope is that my daughter's don't go
through that and I could go there and
say you know what the level at which
they're starting off is so much higher
than the level I'm starting off and
aren't they privileged and look at all
that I didn't have or I can focus their
minds and their ideas at you know you
may start here but the different
of your achievement is not your level
but where you end do you find it
fascinating that people are constantly
attacking that they are they attack
people that have a little bit more to
start which is the whole point of life
you want your children to have more the
only way the only way that it would be
fair it is not because I can't be raised
to their level right the only way to do
it is to bring them down to the level
that I started and how is that fair yeah
right and so again by focusing on the
level that one starts with as a measure
of an individual's achievement I think
is not necessarily focusing on their
individual effort and there are a lot of
people even in India you know as I said
to you my father went from rags to
riches and there were a lot of people
that there were my friends that were
quite rich and they had a very
entitlement mentality you know what I
don't think that they're any happier
then I was even when I was poorer so
this comes back to the point that you
the quote that you had i can't just
measure a person's success by their
economic riches you also happiness which
is what I care about is a state of mind
it's a state of consciousness that has
to be earned self-esteem when combined
with the sense of I'm materially at a
place that I'm comfortable or rich but
more than that psychologically and
intellectually I feel like I've made
something of myself I think Dad is
something that is so much more inspiring
to go after money
you know it's neither used to say money
is the reward not the reason and I
completely agree with that yeah it's so
interesting because I've been thinking
about this a lot lately because
obviously the show is kind of catching
fire and I'm doing okay
financially and we're building something
good and I'm traveling a lot people say
nice things to me all the time and I've
been thinking about that and people keep
saying well you're gonna get some big
offer from one of these networks or
something but but I love this like I'm
actually happy now like I'm doing what I
think I'm supposed to be doing and I
don't know where that road
but looking at everything holistically
it's not just about money it's about
doing something that gives you value and
all that but we seem not to focus enough
but that's the point right I get so much
joy so again to that quote that you were
talking about for me the journey is the
destination you know whether I I feel
younger today than I did when I was 20
years old and what's the big difference
I feel like I have earned the
self-esteem not recognition outside
because people you know and you know
this you meet a lot of people and they
come to you and say hey Dave you're so
great but who is saying you're great
makes a big difference to you hearing
whether you see what I mean so there has
to be a sense of do I believe that
you're saying I'm great for the reasons
that I value and if that is there then I
will take external adulation as a
positive if not it's Hollow
it's empty so self esteem is truly what
one should be striving for yeah do you
think at some level capitalism and maybe
the Western world in a wider sense is
suffering from success at the moment
that it almost seems like because we've
been so successful we're now going to
that place that we mentioned earlier
where we're just fighting over little
differences where then there's a lot of
people right now I mean if you talk
about socialism on college campuses
you'll you'll sell out the room you know
and if you talk about fortunately I find
when I go and I mostly talked to
libertarian or capitalist or whatever
groups you know we're doing quite well
as well but that the ideas that are
completely contrary to everything you've
just said seem to be gaining some
momentum so I don't think they're
victims of our success
I think we're victims of the fact that
we have never really sat down and
thought seriously about the reasons for
our success and by eschewing that
intellectual thought and ideas that
under underpin our success we have
actually sold our success short how
should we have done that do you mean uh
that our politicians should have talked
about it more or you mean
more in academia I think it starts from
K through 12 education actually I think
that we have taken this concept we we
have short-circuited our mind in K
through 12 education all the way through
college and this comes back to your
example of the faculty adviser that does
not want to be challenged by their
students when you have the mentality as
a teacher whether it's in K through 12
or as a professor in academia where I
know what is best and I am going to tell
you what it is as opposed to facilitate
your learning process we are not
training our students how to think
anymore we're not giving them the
ability to learn in the manner that they
do I'll give you another example
memorization cut off as a huge negative
today but you know Sir Anthony Leggett
who was annabelle or it was a Nobel
laureate and a professor at Illinois
which is where I was give this inspiring
speech to middle schoolers one day and
the theme of it was the more you know
the more you know what you don't know
knowledge is a building on process you
have to learn first to then learn what
you need to learn again and so fostering
that spirit in students will then allow
you to go back to first principles so
it's not about being an expert on any
area but it's about any area that you
choose to go in there don't just look at
the outcomes don't just look at the
success factors and then try to emulate
the symptoms if you will or the the
things that accompany success go down to
the very fundamental levels of what are
the ideas and what are the first
principles that enable success to begin
with it's interesting because this seems
to be a place where maybe technology has
harmed us because it's like instead of
having a holistic and integral view of
really knowing what you're talking about
well what do we do we google it so you
know you know
you'll get there right maybe yeah there
we go yeah but you but you'll get just
the quick answer instead of going to the
root of what your is where I'd say again
technology is a tool it does not absolve
us of our responsibility on how we use
the tool
I'm actually a huge fan of Google yeah
Google Scholar has made my life so much
easier I remember being a doctoral
student having to go through Lockwood
Lockwood library in 6 feet of snow in
Buffalo weather right if I wanted an
answer to a question now Google Scholar
allows me to do it in seconds know what
microfiche is exactly and I had to do my
data gathering yeah but but the point
out here is I can use Google Scholar to
get just an amazing amount of knowledge
at my fingertips how great is that
I mean I am so thankful to technology to
do that but that does not absolve me of
the responsibility of saying here is all
of the pieces of information in fact I
would say this age of information
technology the need of the mind to have
judgment and to discern across all these
pieces of information is that an
all-time high
yeah so obviously you teach and you talk
about entrepreneurial spirit and
entrepreneurship one of the things that
I think is fascinating related to
technology right now is that Peter Thiel
is leaving Silicon Valley because he
feels that collectivism leftism cultural
Marxism maybe you have some other
phrases for whatever that is has sort of
crushed the ability to think so that
there isn't the creativity coming out of
Silicon Valley that there used to be
which is why we don't have that many new
apps anymore we don't have that many new
breaking technologies and he is a
capitalist and he's ironically moving to
LA to become freer which is sort of
where people don't think of us as a
capitalist Haven here in California yeah
and LA specifically do you find that
fascinating that that Silicon Valley
seems to lean so far left and yet is
supposed to be the place of innovation
you know now that you're saying that I
just made a connection that I never
thought of my
represents exactly that if you think
about it right he was very free market
oriented as it came to the economic
realm and being entrepreneurial in terms
of creating new products and services
and economic riches but when it came
time to thinking he was very
traditionalist and I think that that
bifurcation this mind-body dichotomy if
you will is what's plaguing a lot of
people right now so I am NOT an expert
on Silicon Valley i have noticed of
course that a lot of people so facebook
I just I just saw Mark Zuckerberg say
something to the effect of you should
have economic regulation on social media
it's like huh the whole reason why you
were successful it's because you did not
have any barriers to entry the best way
to keep a monopoly is to have government
regulation because again that's the use
of force right if I cannot go into an
industry because there is prohibition so
think about uber and what Hoover had to
deal with in the taxicab industry think
about when Airlines was not what we know
it because they were just that regulated
carriers right yeah that's imminent
monopoly and the best way for
entrepreneur who has achieved success
but now no longer wants to continue to
own their success is to say let me
create barriers to entry through
government regulation so I can be
protected by any entrepreneur such as me
right those days ago right right to then
come and infringe on what I have it's
almost as if he's trying to protect what
he has yeah think maybe you think you
know it's so funny also how these things
change because you know 15 years ago
before over when I lived in New York
City basically my whole adult life and
people would complain relentlessly about
the cabs they're all broken down their
drivers aren't friendly they don't pick
you up if you're a certain color etc etc
then uber comes around fixes a lot of
these problems by ingenuity and now
people are saying you see what they did
they put the cabs
of business the same people who were
upset the first in Boston it's even
worse in Boston every uber or lyft ride
has to be has to pay five scientists
sense of a surcharge and every you know
a fraction of that I don't remember
whether it's two cents or three cents
but you know it adds up when millions of
right goes to the taxicab industry
that's incredible to the industry that's
actually being replaced by the time
doing better sir yes yes exactly so that
just so then is there a flaw in
capitalism there somehow because that
there's probably some cronyism that's
allowing the politicians to write these
ridiculous laws phony ISM is not about
markets cronyism is about statism
cronyism is not capital as a network it
is government regulation at work and it
this comes back to you know Dave you're
successful I take pride in watching your
videos simply because I enjoy it
but there I'm sure is a bit of envy to
about gee I wish I could be as eloquent
as Davis and and as the five hundred
thousand people that watch the day Rubin
show you know Wow wouldn't I love to
have that kind of an impact now that
send me on my part there are two things
I could do it can either be a positive
driver of my energies I could say I want
what Dave does has but I don't have and
that can put me on a growth mindset
entrepreneurial mindset what is it that
I need to do in order to achieve those
success factors going back to first
principles what are the reasons behind
their success and what can I do to
emulate or do differently than they or I
can say no I want what Dave has but I
don't need to earn it I don't need to do
that so let me get the government to
take some of what dave has some of
Dave's sponsorship right and that's what
income inequality and redistribution is
all about I'm taking some of your
viewership and I'm going to be four
those people - now listen to me so
that's where we're using government
force whether it's income redistribution
or any kind of yardstick of value where
we re distributing we're saying we're
gonna take it from you and that actually
negates your viewers rights right
because now if I have the government
saying that then some of them would be
forced to not watch you but watch me
yeah on the other hand there's jealousy
by the way the difference between envy
and jealousy one of my colleagues just
told me recently envy is when I want
something I don't have jealousy is when
I want to keep something that I have but
I'm being threatened against right again
positive or negative if I feel jealousy
because I feel threatened about what I'm
about to lose I can go ahead and say
what is it that I need to do in order to
keep it or I can create barriers and say
you can't have it through the use of
force the same principles that work at
cronyism at both sides of the yardstick
so when we talk about relative poverty
in the United States as an income
inequality by the way coming from India
I know what true poverty is we in the
United States the minimum level of
poverty here is so much better than the
rest of the world so if we care again
it's about envy these rich people have
what I don't have and I should get them
or on the rich end of the spectrum I
have this as a wealthy person regardless
of whether I got it out of an
inheritance or because of prior
entrepreneurial thinking it's being
threatened but I want to keep it for
myself so the best way for me to do that
is to lobby the government and erect
barriers to entry on both sides the use
of governmental regulation to respond to
envy and jealousy is a negative not a
positive driver of economic growth so
where do you where do you draw the line
or where is the starting point then of
what government is supposed to do a
government has a legal monopoly on force
as it should because you and I in a
civil society cannot focus our my
in our effort on creating value if we're
always gonna worry about somebody
looting or taking things away from us
right so I am NOT an anarchist
I believe in governments I believe in
the rule of law I believe in the
protection so there are basic functions
of the government that absolutely are
essential beyond that keep the economy
away from the realm of the government
because the government's only ability to
do something is to say you in your best
judgment think you should go eh
I am Telling You you need to go B you're
forcing the mind do not think or act on
their best judgment yeah so it's
interesting in the in the case of uber
and what you were describing in Boston
and the pennies going back to the to the
cabbies who have nothing to do with it
that actually is because of regulation
and that the only way to eliminate that
and let new businesses thrive is let
them thrive just let's just unleash them
let them know all right so there's a
couple more things that I want to do
with you and you had a for questions
about personal leadership then you asked
a lot of your students and I thought
that these were really great yes
and it really this I think sort of puts
a nice bow on everything that we've
talked about here
so the first one is what is your purpose
kids must be kids students must be they
must look at you kind of kind of
curiously when you ask them that one
because that's a that's a big one yeah
so let me spend two seconds just telling
you about why I came up with this
framework yeah I'm a strategy and
entrepreneurship professor and I was
asked to teach in a program which was
largely minority high school student
based and I was asked to give a lecture
on strategic management and strategic
management is typically the realm of
CEOs how can high schoolers identify and
associate with questions that a CEO has
to deal with that was the big challenge
that I had how am I supposed to talk to
them about at that time what Steve Jobs
is doing for Apple even though there
nice Apple and make it real to them and
I realize I don't need to do that I
could say to them especially because
there are thus cusp of identifying who
they are and creating their identity
you're the CEO of me incorporated are
you thinking like a CEO what are the
four fundamental questions that a CEO
should ask and are you asking those
questions of yourself and it begins with
the first one is what is your purpose
the second is what does success look
like
the third is what's my value proposition
given that that's my purpose and that's
what success looks like and then finally
in this Stumpf's a lot of people with
whom should I trade yeah so these four
questions I think are the essence of any
entrepreneurial individual or any
entrepreneurial organization how often
when you ask these students these
questions do they have some good answers
oh my gosh these are tough I mean these
what is your purpose these are the
questions of all time examining them in
the framework of business and
entrepreneurship or themselves actually
so I I I'm actually agnostic about
whether they want to define what is your
purpose as it relates to their career or
as it relates to their life but the
answers that I provide them in the
context of thinking and you would be
amazed as to how much this resonates all
the way from beginning high schoolers
including my own daughter who was forced
to take this class with me to executives
in my Executive MBA so what is your
purpose really requires people to think
about what problems do I want to solve
that are meaningful to me so it again
comes to making the world a better place
to live by doing something important to
yourself and you know people say Oh
making the world a better place to live
or come on Rhodri right but what is it
what is your world Dave what is my world
it's the places you go the people you
meet and the things that you do and if
in doing these three things you have
solved a problem and made it a better
place then you've made a world a better
place but you've done it by focusing on
things that are important to you yeah so
it's interesting you you're talking
about all these things through the
business lens but really what you're
talking about you said before which is
which is happiness yes absolutely yeah
and in fact on that point so what does
success look like to me it is the
ability to say I love what I do
and I'm good at it because that's the
virtuous spiral that enables self-esteem
and then you have self esteem because
you're good at something you want to
invest in it to become even better at it
yeah it's pretty cool waking up with
that that feeling so that was number two
what does execs success look like you
mentioned all of them already but I just
want to spend a little bit so what is
your value proposition so notice that
the answer to the question what does
success look like takes an inward
perspective what do I love and then what
are my abilities that will help get me
to where I love and what I'm good at
what is my value proposition is still
looking at your abilities but now the
yardstick is how is it creating value to
you so clearly I love enterprise and
innovation right yeah I love what I do I
think I'm I'm pretty good at it you're
pretty good I come up every morning with
a spring in my step but why would that
cause you to want to use you know ask
Rajshri to join you this morning as
opposed to multiple other people that
you do so what's my value proposition to
you what benefit do I offer you with the
features that are unique to me that is
the focus on value proposition yeah and
it's obvious because we have the
evidence right here because of all the
people that I talked to that weekend you
were one of I think two people who I
said to the learn Liberty guys we're
gonna get our own show yeah you came up
to me after we had a great conversation
about all of this stuff and there you go
and then finally with who should I train
that is the one thing that stumps a lot
of people and goes back to the what is
my purpose making the world a better
place to live by doing something
important to me right so providing
benefit to someone else but making sure
that I'm been
fitting and I'm doing something I love
to the answer to what the success look
like is really getting to what you love
doing which is about you the answer to
your value proposition is providing
benefit to someone else
right making the world a better place to
live with whom do you trade is bringing
those two together so you and I are
trading right now we may not be
exchanging any dollars but there's a
trade going on out here
and that relates to your abilities and
your aspirations and my abilities and my
aspirations and we're combined together
with a common objective so the alignment
of your aspirations and my abilities are
what's gonna determine our actions and
in doing so I get to do what I love
doing I offer you a benefit so do you
and it's a win-win trade well I got to
do what I love doing here I feel that we
I think we did almost everything is
there anything that we possibly missed
this was this was truly a pleasure
because this was exactly what I've tried
to do in my life and with this show and
everything else and and your you just
exude exactly what you're talking about
thank you oh joy to see yes and and in
fact that's exactly why I want to trade
with you I love hanging with you right
because you exude the same positive
can-do sense of life and I would rather
have people around me that have that
same spirit make me better make me more
energized than people that either I
bring down or they bring down you know
or they bring me can we do a live event
together can we do something Marylyn all
right we're gonna make something happen
sounds good this was this was truly a
pleasure I'm glad it happened to
everyone and for more on Rajshri you can
check out her website which we've linked
to right down below
[Music]
you